all right okay
um play d4 got an international master
here from
greece macro
okay some
playing some kind of i don't know old
indian
modern defense mixture
yeah d5 is an important move in this
kind of position
to um
to get some space here and um
keep his pawn on e7 to
be a potential point of attack here
yeah my bishop
gets a good position here on g2 it
protects this
strong pawn and potentially um
this diagonal is opened up later
and still in the long run he needs to
take care about e7 first i'd like to
complete the development of course like
rook c1 rookie one
and then see what happens next
hmm not quite sure what he's getting at
maybe he wants to play queen before some
pressure on c4
i could play queen b3 myself
okay
yeah maybe it's okay
i was a bit worried at first about
knight to g4 because i simply
i covered the square before and i don't
want to really give this bishop but
okay b7 is hanging if it plays in ig4 i
can maybe just take
maybe i can take b7 not sure
i really should have
taken this into account before i played
knight b3
only uh consolation here is that he's um
spending even more time than i usually
do
maybe even take with the knight and then
with the bishop
to open up the bishops here
okay what what is his next move maybe
knight c5
if i then play queen c2 we might even
take on a2 so maybe i could
i should just play a move like a3 here
it's not the most powerful move in a way
he's also got knight a4 then or queen a4
yeah knight c5 is somewhat annoying
maybe a3 knight c5 and queen b5
yeah i thought this would maybe an idea
even to sacrifice b2 but
looking at this um
now i think it's just a bad idea
but maybe on knight c5 i can go queen a2
knight d3 is not such an issue
okay i need to go back here
strange move if you ask me e6
not quite sure what the idea
just weakens d6 i think it's not a huge
huge problem but um
why why why would he do that it was
wasn't necessary at all
okay i'd like to play before really
maybe prepare this here
all right
yeah okay now g4 i can prevent
okay what now c5
getting um getting this past pawn
not quite sure if this is a good idea it
could be a good idea but
it's not completely killed
clear-cut i could also go g4
and he needs to
go with the queen to uh sit really
straight square on h4
okay let's
get him to this somewhat strange looking
square
okay this is just a piece for nothing
i just need to be a little bit careful
okay
yeah deform maybe that's an idm
time warning yeah this is some
also
what's a serious idea
trying to rearrange my pieces somehow
i'd like to play queen d3 bishop d2 and
get some coordination here you can play
d4d3 this is
maybe the main main idea
queen d1 is most likely my next move
queen d1
f3 or something the bishop on d2 is
blocking the pawn
and he's very slow
yeah most likely and loose on time black
forfeits on time yeah i played very
slowly
but okay this is this is really just an
extra piece
for close to nothing
and i don't know queen h4 was it so bad
yeah it doesn't look great yeah but
still i wouldn't i wouldn't have taken
there
yeah i think
maybe unless he got some
some tactical um stuff here to
take use of my myp setup here which is a
bit artificial for okay
for i wanted to move some i'm very good
here
or maybe maybe black is still
halfway okay but but this this e6 stuff
and then continuing so passively is this
is just better for white
yeah okay next game